as college and he will be on presenting
teaching with virtuous during
cooperating supplemental instruction and
i'm just going to pass out a 10mg and
then before the end of the session i
last took a lot of evaluation so welcome
so I mean I'm Greg Sadler and I teach
philosophy some religious studies
classes as well various prices and
manages philosophy especially critical
thinking and ethics classes I've used
supplemental instruction in two ways one
where it was officially supplemental
instruction where we've been pretty
extensive use of it for my critical
thinking classes where we had a very
high dfw bring these apps of the times
so that's a measure of how students are
doing which class you were quite class
any class at at high dfw rate got
supplemental instruction resources at
Fayetteville State University's my job
before that I taught actually at Indiana
State Prison and four-year degree
program and we didn't have supplemental
instruction but what we did he have was
a very strong community of education
there because men were you know there
for a long time had gone through the
program would counsel each other a bit
with Lady each other and we actually had
dedicated tutors well that that program
last that we could we instructors could
work with pretty directly so when the
this conference was brought up and
I asked what you want to think about
contributing anything I thought well
what could what could I bring in terms
of philosophy and so I'm not going to
talk a lot about pedagogy per se I'm
going to talk about how one moral theory
that we call virtue ethics would
intersect with some of the things that
we talk about scholarship of teaching
and learning a little bit more
thematically and what I've done actually
it is i've written a paper that i'm
still working on so i'm going to read
the paper we could stop it at different
points if you want to and do questions
or you could just wait until the end and
then have a long discussion about that's
all good ok so the thing that I want to
think about is what sorts of skills and
dispositions do we need to attend to to
think about to cultivate in order to
render supplemental instruction highly
effective pedagogical resource and the
first three answers to this question
that are the most likely ones are things
like disciplinary knowledge or you know
pedagogical competency or you know this
broad category that we often label those
people skills it's not something like we
have to think about moral theory you
know think about ethics what I'm going
to talk about here is one particular
kind of moral theory that we call virtue
ethics and I'm going to talk about
another type of set of skills and
dispositions the virtues that we call
intellectual moral so for about the next
25 minutes or so since you've committed
to be reading the paper I'm going to be
sketching out a broadly Aristotelian
virtue ethics framework and I'm going to
say that supplemental instruction could
be profitably located within this and
further thought up in conjunction with
it so what I'm not saying X I want to
make this very clear right off the bat
is that this would be some sort of
substitute for any of the other things
that we want to think about or do so I'm
not saying
let's replace training that's very
attentive state of study skills or
things like that with with virtue ethics
but I think it could be a good adjunct
something that was compliment what we're
thinking about and so multiple sets of
skills and dispositions are needed or
desirable for both instructors and
students who are supplemental
instruction leaders or coaches expertise
in an academic discipline and what
happens to be the subject matter is one
of the three important things that we
normally look at that almost goes
without saying but I think it's worth
dwelling on this because one of the
prevalent misconceptions that we have to
disabuse our students of so often is
that learning and expertise is largely
just a matter of acquired information
rather than acquiring and developing a
battery of skills some of these are
general like written communication or
critical thinking others very specific
to the subject matters but often
susceptible transfer analogy to other
contexts that's what we want them to to
get even deeper than skills and equally
important are what we call dispositions
developed habits generally attitudes
looks and approach is effective
orientations patterns of desire and
emotional response in one of the main
fields that I work in critical thinking
that field of performance and expertise
has long been identified by one of the
most rigorous disciplinary models and
social studies the APA Delphi report
critical thinking as consisting
specifically in skills and then
dispositions not just skills within a
classical Aristotelian philosophy of
education an assemblage of interlocking
and scaffold acknowledges skills and
dispositions has a particular name they
call that a hexose or a habits terms
Greek to Latin terms have been used in
some other context they become sort of
like a possession rooted in the being of
the knower and when they're developed we
call this an intellectual virtue so that
that's some of the terminology
you hear me talking about virtue he said
what's he talking about there that
sounds awfully moralistic when we talk
about a virtue we mean some type of
excellence but what is an excellence
it's something that one does over and
over again is rooted within one it's not
just something that one does
occasionally if it's one's excellence
now as all of us know some of us having
been schooled by painful experience
there's an art and expertise who's proud
whose product is consistently teaching
well and this is different from although
it does bear affinities with certain
types of disciplinary expertise you know
any mathematics or philosophy or history
one can be a great scholar in a
particular field yet teach material one
that one knows in ways that are
confusing uninformative even inscrutable
21 students you've all seen instructors
like that or perhaps at one point I'll
cop to this myself having been that
student so this is the second kind of
skills and desirable dispositions that
is susceptible of being taught even
formalized to certain systems and some
degree then there's this broad category
of things that we call people skills and
that I understand it's a very vague
category to invoke and we're not going
to actually go into it in any sort of
detail here but the reason I'm bringing
it up is to contrast that with another
set of skills and dispositions that we
study in ethics that we call the virtues
now an ideal instructor develops and
possesses exhibits integrative models
all of these sort of things all the time
real instructors like ourselves of
course do these more or less well more
or less consistently stronger in some
areas at particular times in certain
types of situations and others hopefully
improving on the way reflecting on good
and bad experiences adding to our areas
of strength and expertise through
through theoretical study like
scholarship of teaching and learning
interaction with their peers like we're
doing here appropriating useful or
engaging resources like some of the
things
here as well putting things into
practice and that reassessment you know
this constant process of improvement as
a result or better put through these
processes education occurs learning
takes place within through and by
students more or less successfully
hopefully the students come out of our
classes not only having learned
disciplinary information at a surface
level but a deeper more attentive level
that that signifying will you talk about
habitus so this again nothing really
surprising here is maybe a little bit of
terminology that's different from one
way of looking at it to another they
might have also developed some
competencies in pedagogy themselves
depending on what you're doing with them
or you know that you may have worked on
on these broad people skills things
communication skills ability to
empathize with other people adding an SI
leader or any sort of intermediary like
a teaching assistant or it's hooter
writers these matters more complex since
the intermediary functions as an
instructor albeit in a different kind of
different level in different ways and as
a student I'll be eight a student with a
higher more integrated grasp of the
course material there's also the
question of the degree to in the ways
which the instructor teaches interacts
with and philosophers the development of
the SI leader and the feedback about or
insight into the students provided to
the instructor by the SI leader who has
a unique and useful vantage point from
which to observe and interact with
students so with this more complex and
potentially more productive arrangement
outline now we can raise the question of
whether what is going on or what could
potentially be going on would want to be
going on and what we as instructors
would like to be going on these aren't
always the same thing can be adequately
conceptualized just in terms of
disciplinary knowledge medical
pedagogical expertise and people skills
so what I'm trying to say here is that
you can do that and it may must do do
that but that adding virtue adding a
virtue ethics perspective would
contribute something more not something
that you're going to be able to directly
measure
I suspect there-there actually is some
work being done in assessment of moral
development especially in the Northeast
with some pilot studies that are going
on but I'm not going to go into that
here because I'm I'm aware of but not
familiar with that research so all of
these are important but i would say i
would like to say that and to some
extent say why and how thinking about SI
in terms of the family of approaches and
moral theory that we call virtue ethics
contributes to developing a yet more
adequate understanding of what's still
more effective use of SI look like so
before doing these things i want to
reiterate once again some of the things
I'm actually saying and some of the
things that not because I find that when
I when I talk about ethics one of the
by-products is often people get get a
get upset and say who are you that you
don't be pushing this sort of thing and
there's a lot of controversy so I am
saying that virtue ethics provides a
needed complement to other more
explicitly pedagogical and less
explicitly moral theoretical approaches
I'm not suggesting that virtue ethics is
in any way is substitute for these other
approaches i'm also not saying that the
instructor who's disciplinary competence
lies and some other field now needs to
become a moral philosopher start doing
that sort of thing full time i am saying
that some of the typical components of a
virtue ethics approach can be adopted
and appropriate as useful portions of
one's own approach to effective
employment of si leaders and I think
these components do that in two ways
there are some ideas or considerations
that a virtue ethics approach provides
that are unlikely to be provided or even
realized as needed in its absence and
then there's also a lot of ideas and
considerations that are always on the
table what often don't get the emphasis
that they probably could use because our
other approaches are focused on other
other ends other measures other
interests so what I plan to do this this
talk before opening up the Florida you
know
whatever we want to do discussion we can
ask questions we can dialogue I'm going
to try to do four things very quickly
one of them is to give a very brief
overview of virtue ethics as a camera
theory then I'm going to look at the
purposes of half guess I was didn't that
sort of framework after that I'm going
to discuss which virtues and vices are
important to focus on to ensure that
effective use of Si and then I'm going
to talk very very briefly about how
these are actually developed what we
might want to think about in terms of
our si leaders so what does virtue
ethics I'm guessing that this is a term
that most of you encountered at one
point along along the line in your
education in taking an intro philosophy
class or an ethics class you may have
studied it more or less extensively but
on if you're like my students then you
probably actually retain the name but
not entirely those yeah so I'm going to
talk a little bit there's a lot of you
know terms that we learn along the way
and then we forget exactly where they
feel so virtue ethics is one of the main
well established and coherent moral
theories which we teach in various
ethics and applied ethics courses it
represents a family of moral theories so
it includes say Plato and Aristotle
theories have also includes some
non-western theories like that Confucius
it also includes those who have
interpreted them down to the modern day
so to include contemporary philosophers
like Martha Nussbaum or Hellstrom
McIntyre one of the distinctive features
shared by all these various virtue
ethics and this family is making virtues
and vices or the array of good and bad
moral dispositions that are developed
over time as habits three actions and
choices of central consideration in
evaluating the goodness or badness the
rightness or wrongness the
appropriateness are going to appropriate
appropriate
of actions and other things so virtue
ethics is different and that doesn't
look immediately at actions it looks at
states of character and some sort of
shifts the focus instead of focusing
just on conformity to rules or following
moral or professional codes or
calculating best outcomes or displaying
compassion or even on other broad
ethical principles virtue ethics goes
beyond it situates all of you in
relation to three other sets of manners
one is reframing thinking about these
things in terms of human flourishing
excellence and then means and ends one
is identifying the actual ranges of
habits and dispositions we want to look
at the virtues and devices and then the
other thing is actually thinking about
how are these foster how are these
brought about so it makes good sense to
start by stepping back momentarily and
asking a few questions many of us
routinely ask these sort of questions
similar intent through diff though
different scope as part of our work as
educators when carrying out integrated
course design for example or there
because this goes by many different
names that the basic idea is you start
by thinking about what you actually want
to achieve and then you start looking at
you know the means in order to attain
that and the means in order to attain
that backwards design it's also called
when you're doing that you're doing what
we call practical reasoning so we're
going to do that here and we can broaden
the horizons of this sort of questioning
when it comes to si and this is what
virtue ethics actually does and when it
comes to education it asks what is the
purpose where the goods achieved by what
are the goods necessaries conditions for
what is the end of education what counts
as excellence when it comes to teaching
when it comes to learning and asking and
attempting to answer these kinds of
questions opens up even bigger questions
which we're going to avoid here which is
you know notice we can ask this about an
SI leader we getting asked what is the
purpose of an SI debater often this gets
left out
I didn't put this in the paper but one
of my experiences in having an SI leader
was having them suddenly thrust upon me
and say here's the resource you got to
use them and then you start thinking oh
ha manda integrate this into my class
where we got my syllabus form and so the
first semester that my ass I leader you
know it's mainly my fault was pretty
useless and these sort of things only
get better when we think about these
sort of questions how are we going to
integrate them while answering that
depends on what you want an SI leader to
actually do and that's not just a matter
of purely in a personal choice or you
know ad-hoc things you come up with fly
you probably should actually sit down
and think what what is the actual
purpose of what are we doing this for
what are the goods there instrumental in
producing what what constitutes
excellence in their specific type of
educational activity a number of varied
purposes come to mind when we ask why we
have and how we can use an SI leader the
broadest most overarching one is of
course to improve student learning in
our courses what is that the eight and
how does that take determinate form that
this came up earlier today and that
session when people started asking about
assessment that's one way of looking at
it right how can we actually tell
whether this is doing any good whether
we're just you know throwing money away
as does the administrator sometimes so
yeah how does that take the determinant
floor well at the very least si leaders
provide contact hours in addition to our
own class time and waffle it'll use
office hours during which students are
in the aging of course they also provide
much more individuate at hands-on
instruction for students with tender
their sessions they cover the material
sometimes from different vantage points
same material that looked at in a
different way
suddenly open it up for a student they
provide additional examples or
applications needed to help students
wrap their heads around course concepts
so what they're doing is they're
supporting and extending the teaching
built into the course structured by the
instructor like course instructors si
leaders help students progress towards
what is the center with the goods of
knowledge whether pursued for merely
instrumental reasons or towards
intrinsic values what is distinctive to
si leaders as opposed to tutors or TAS
other going to media raises two things
they're all undergraduate students at
that institution which could be the case
for it true there but rarely the case
for a TA right there are more or less
the same level as the students with whom
they're engaged and more specifically
their students who excelled in that
particular course with that particular
professor both of these provide si
leaders with distinct advantages in
reaching and assisting students they're
regarded as peers of a sort as living
examples they are and how one can excel
in a course ticular professor so they're
viewed as particularly well-informed not
just about a given subject in general
but in a more specific way how their
assigned professors lectures the course
teaches the material evaluate student
performance these are often the things
students are asking her are at least in
my experience about what's how's the
grading going to take place so what
makes an S IV to excellent we
instructors need to know this not only
so we can recognize we're fortunate
enough to have excellent SI views but
also so we can steer the SI leaders we
recruit towards the needed forms and
dimensions of excellence and one example
that a gift here rethinking this is you
might suppose that the greater quicker
mastery of potential SI leader
demonstrates of course material the more
effective he or she will be but that's
not necessarily so in some respects it's
far better to employ an SI leader who
well intelligent has struggled at some
points or in certain matters with the
material since such a student now
teaching possess is an effective and
intellectual grasp of the starting
condition of many students some
understanding of what's
choir to go beyond that and an ability
to model the means and possibility of
success to their peers ideally you would
want an SI leader to be continuing their
own education in the subject matter so
if it's a beginning level critical
thinking class like the one that I
thought I would want an SI leader to be
continuing on and studying some
additional things outside of the class
that fall within that so that they are
growing you want them to be expanding
their expertise deserting their own weak
points and working on those deepening
their understanding si leaders need to
be good students already doing well and
on an established trajectory towards
further improvement and likewise they
need to be developing teachers towards
developing excellence in these two roles
in the particular combination si leaders
requires some degree a development of
one intellectual virtue that we identify
a Chilean way as from Asus or another
translation practical wisdom the ability
to go beyond the rules go beyond
procedures and see what needs to be
applied to particular cases and that's
something that has to be developed over
time it doesn't come automatically it's
not just a knack that that people have
it's something that is a habit they are
also going to require i'm going to say
some development and understanding of
the moral virtues certain moral virtues
to what our moral virtues their habitual
dispositions that are gradually by
practice established within a person's
character or personality they take the
form of typically and characteristically
acting feeling making use of things in
good or right ways and the person who is
virtuous possesses right assessments and
attitudes towards what's to be done what
goods are at stake and how they want
best to be ordered or pursued or produce
to a protective so possession and
practice of the virtues
ethics is what enabled what enables a
person to flourish indeterminate ways
what enables them to realize that
potential and 28 others in flourishing
as well and realizing their own
potential since Aristotle's own time
it's been recognized that these tend to
be intermediate states and that the
other types of habits that we want to
avoid with all vices tend to be extreme
states a few other things need to be
said about this this notion in virtue
it's possible for a person to do
virtuous actions without him or herself
being actually virtuous that is having
an established in their character so one
might act in the way of virtuous person
would as just or moderate or mr.
courageous but just on occasion that's
not yet having virtue one might behave
consistently in the way virtuous people
tend to but not because one shoes is
that recognizing that that's the right
thing to do or that it's quick for its
own sake but just to earn a reward or
avoid a punishment or something like
them you can even recognize the goodness
of a virtue and the need you actually
have for it you can will the practice of
consistently and not yet be virtuous as
when we're trying to improve our
characters if I recognize that for
instance I heat too much characteristic
language and that I don't yet have the
the virtue of moderation at least with
respect to to food I can still you know
decide I want to change that that
doesn't mean that just by deciding that
I'm automatically there but that's
that's a step on the way so moral
virtues are really sets of dispositions
and skills having interconnected
practical effective and intellectual
dimensions so now we get to the part
where we talk about specific virtues and
as I thought this through and I've been
thinking about different ways of
understanding the virtues for quite some
time as I thought this in terms of si I
came up with a list of eight I'm not
saying this is the be-all and end-all
and there's perfect
I opened a revision or addition or there
might be reasons why some of these
aren't particularly needed I'm not
saying that you have to have these in
order to be an SI leader I'm saying that
the possession of these would actually
make a person a better SI leader so I
came up with a list of seven virtues and
one thing that's sort of like virtue but
but actually isn't so eight moral trades
particularly relevant to SI are justice
moderation courage generosity honesty
good temper friendliness or compassion
and then self-control or another way of
thinking about that perseverance most of
these are virtues than we recognize your
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics if you
read that bag you know in an ethics
class or in some other class we're not
sure we also assign that but somebody
else does occasionally sure well
actually I'm going to talk about each
one in turn I think so all right so well
I'll go through some justice moderation
courage generosity honesty good temper
friendliness or compassion depending on
how you want to render it prevents
self-control or perseverance and if we
add to this Aristotle's other discussed
virtue Francis or practical wisdom I
think this is this is a good list that
completes what we want to look at so we
have to do more than just name them this
is very often when it comes to talking
about virtue people will put together
charts and they'll say everybody needs
to have these qualities but then they
don't actually tell you what are they
what are they consistent that's why the
Nicomachean ethics is you know that
thick it's not just you know one page
lists that C is a poster on somebody's
wall so we need to analyze them so what
is justice well justice is at bottom a
habitual disposition to give and take
rightly to give other sons their do what
they deserve what one ought to give them
and it take from them or from common
resources once fair share not more than
one scripture often times the specific
shape that justice takes on can be you
know to some degree expressed by laws or
contracts or agreements that we make but
that's what we want to ask badge of
justice one can do what is it what has
agreed to do but following the letter
and subverting spirit wrong familiar
with that sort of thing what we tend to
think of as a work ethic is largely what
in ancient and medieval philosophy we
would call justice actually giving what
is due in relation for your wages
justice also involves treating people
fairly in relation to one another
distributing resources and a balanced
rather than preferential manner that's
going to be important for an SI leader
so a just SI leader would have portion
their time and energy more or less
evenly among the students who come to
them needing assistance doesn't mean
that they do an equally necessarily it
means that they do it proportionately so
if some students are in some ways more
needy of help they're going to give them
more but they're not going to
shortchange everybody else as a result
moderation also called temperance as a
virtue pertains to the uses we make up
in the value assigned to bodily
pleasures I just use this an example of
one more I am NOT where I would like to
be now this virtue is less likely to be
practiced within the context of SI
sessions when si leaders meet with and
students and much it's going to have
much more to do with the larger
framework of a student's life a lot of
these things that we're talking about
are not going to have a direct impact
just in Si the other broader character
based things 1 i'm going to actually go
through this rather quickly because it
looks like
less time than I had thought one thing
that you can exercise moderation with is
time and that's what we're asking of SI
leaves we're not asking them to avoid
bodily pleasures or everything we're
asking I mean that's good thank you but
we're asking them to to manage time well
and this ashley ties in with another
virtue generosity generosity when the
aristotle discusses he has to do with
wealth has to do with what you give to
people the generous person gives fairly
freely but they give for the right time
or they get at the right time for the
right reasons to last people it's not
indiscriminate we would probably want
students to be that way too but not snot
money of course aside readers aren't
doling it out in time if you are
indiscriminate in your use of money or
can discriminate in your use of time and
how you spend it you will invariably
have less when you need it to do good
things so we want si leaders who short
exercise good time management time
management is not just an efficiency
thing it's a moral issue if you look at
it from virtue ethics perspective I'm
going to skip through these rather
quickly and skip over courage and I'm
going to talk honesty we're all familiar
with the notion of honesty as you know
telling the truth and stuff like that
eres level talks about it and I think
this can be very valuable for that site
not in terms of just saying that the cup
is on the table or things like that
Aristotle says it's telling the truth
about oneself one's abilities one's good
qualities one's bad qualities and so the
extreme vices are actually boastfulness
you know sort of arrogance as I leader
could think that they're much better
than everybody else and project that's
everybody else that's not going to be
there
useful SI leader before self-deprecation
you know we often think of humble people
as automatically being good because
they're humble from a virtue ethics
perspective that's not actually the case
you ought to be humble to the extent
that it's merited within the situation
so the SI leader should be conscious of
the fact that they do no more none of
the other students they don't know so
much more that they can lord it over
them but they can't be a good model if
they're not in some respect honest about
about themselves and their their
achievement including what their weak
points I think it makes a person a much
more effective SI leader also a more
effective teacher students can relate to
them easier when you say yeah I'm not so
good at this I struggle with this or I
did struggles I'm going to skip over a
good temper I think all of you can
realize why you know patience is
everything you have with students and
I'm going to talk about how we actually
inculcate so I'm not actually going to
get to all of the virtues if you want
the copy of the paper I'll my cards up
here and people can consent me an email
if we think about how si leaders are to
identify understand practice and develop
these different moral qualities that
we'd like them to have how's that going
to take place one answer is that they
will have to do so in the same way as
everybody else does so how does
everybody else develop virtues
intellectual virtues and moral virtues
are products not only of teaching
progressively acquiring building and
synthesizing knowledge but also through
practice through acting feeling choosing
indeterminate situations in the case of
a moral virtue practice plays a much
more central in fact indispensable role
we become just Aristotle reminds us by
behaving justly over and over again
until with time and repetition it
becomes a habitual thread woven into the
fabric of our character the composite
outcome with myriad choices now settled
into a care
mystic way of being one can read an
heiress level actually says this all the
trees is a moral philosophy that one
likes all the praises of virtuous
dispositions but unless want to actually
practice the choosing doing actions and
according in accordance with virtue this
knowledge is going to remain inoperative
perhaps even seducing the person into
thinking that they have the virtue so
it's not enough just to tell people
here's how you ought to act we have to
find ways to get them to do that to
practice it before they engage students
that set as educators we know that if we
want students to be able to do something
if we want them to acquire deep
structures of skills and dispositions we
not only have to provide them with
models and occasions to practice we
actually do have to provide them with
instruction so what we what we need to
do I'm skipping a little bit how do we
do this with si leaders what else is
needed for them to develop our vision
recognize the need for and make
reasonable progress towards virtuous
characters that will be a key
constituent in their own pursuit of the
good life there's a clue in Aristotle's
dictum that in order to lead well one
must have learned to follow well to take
direction to do what's asked of one to
understand then we can exceed
expectations reasonably placed on one in
order for this to occur they must not
only have followed well they must have
been led well and insofar as they remain
students they must not only continue to
follow a while to learn they must
continue to be led well and to be taught
so this falls upon the instruction an SI
leader might very well realize a certain
virtue is important and necessary for
good teaching just by observing their
instructor and saying well I don't end
up like that guy you know seeing team
and structure losing his or her temper
with students and the fam effect but
that's just telling you what not to do
that's not actually guiding you towards
what you want to be doing what's what's
better to be doing so when it comes down
to it if H is are you actually needed by
si
instructors are going to have to take on
the task of instructing them and guiding
them this in turn is going to require
that the instructors themselves if not
virtue is at least beyond the way to
virtue and he have an adequately
developed degree of knowledge and what
virtue is and what the virtues would
dictate so this makes up a little utopia
right again do you all have to become
professional moral philosophers in order
for this to be possibility i don't i
don't think so but it would take going
beyond the way we typically think about
the side which is largely in terms of
very legitimate goals of passing on
disciplinary knowledge and accessible
outcomes this is a sort of a broader
scope so it is kind of a large-scale
project which I'm sure is open to many
objections which I'm perfectly willing
to entertain now nobody's got any
objections yeah there was an interesting
piece in The New York Times Magazine a
couple of weeks ago about Kens can the
student learn success or failure oh yeah
right yeah and there were the
interesting pieces in this case I think
was that a lot of students or you know
the students who have actually dealt
with that have dealt with challenging
familial issues or I've really developed
those resources at our yeah now things
could go one of two ways sometimes
people face challenges they responded
and badly and they end up having bad
character as a result and that makes
them less able to respond to situations
well but yet you can't from a virtue
ethics perspective you can't expect
people to actually be good who have not
been challenged we haven't faced some
you can't expect somebody to be just who
hasn't actually faced some situations
where they were tempted
one thing and then somehow ended up
doing the right thing and then keep
doing this that's what so there you know
there may be something to this notion
that sometimes we hold this the students
hands a little bit too much we want them
when they fail a lot of life is they
actually figure out what to do have you
screwed things up power not just screwed
up worse I think virtue ethics is good
for that sort of thing a lot of other I
think should say hey don't screw it up
you know but but the reality is we begin
very often are thinking about these
things the after I just think like given
that SI is this is what it's like I
think a really interesting way of kind
of supporting students who really have
had more than their share of challenges
yeah you know I just wonder you know
just to think another thing to throw out
you know I for the SI leader themselves
I think that it I would much rather have
an SI leader who was a b-plus student
than an A student and who would have
been a C student if they hadn't put in a
lot of work who struggled with one
chapter in particular intensity I did
poorly on this and here's how talking to
their fellow students here's how you're
not going to importance because I think
people can relate to that
some super achievers student has never
screwed up but then the super achiever
doesn't everybody's going to now go by
aerosoles Nick McCain FHP you have to
find you a virtue but you're asking for
reflection which is the part of those
those 80 are wonderful by the inability
to some backup failure or success yeah
please hold I'm not saying whether these
are the key elements I'm saying that
this would be add to the things yeah
reflection in order to make progress
whether whether it's just in terms of
prior disciplinary knowledge or in terms
of developing virtues there has to be an
element of reflection and you can
actually talk about people who liked
well and people who doubt and that can
also be habitual to that would be in the
category that Arizona calls the
intellectual virtues Aristotle actually
can't talk about all these things we've
made plenty of progress as the but
virtue ethics perspective starting from
them then going going on further
the other
okay well thank you very much for
entertaining this this idea and will
spit up some you sphere